Paco has been working
on the Landing Page
and thinks it's ready
to be tested on the Internet
with the first version
of his application.
In the first instance,
he needs to register it
with Google App Engine,
which he will accomplish
by following a very simple
guided procedure.
Upon finishing,
he will be assigned the permits
and his resources
on the platform.
START NEW APPLICATION
CREATION WIZARD
To start, Paco enters
appengine.google.com
in his navigator,
previously authorized
with his Google account,
which will remain associated
as the owner of the application.
For his first application,
Paco will only see the button
saying "Create Application",
which he'll click on.
ID AND APP NAME
The next step is assigning
a unique identifier,
which involves various details.
It needs to coincide
with the value Paco registered
in the Application field
of the app.yaml file
from lesson 2,
where he made the Landing Page.
As a result,
the root URL address
assigned to his app
will have the following format:
identificador.appspot.com.
This address
is about a predetermined
Google App Engine domain,
and Paco will use it
to access the application,
especially during
its development.
Keep in mind
that this identifier
needs to be available
and meet some requisites
about the amount
and kind of characters,
trademark, among others.
The identifier
cannot be modified later.
It cannot be used again either,
not even after
deleting the application.
This is due to that
the identifier functions
as a key and remains associated
in various systems internally.
The application
needs to have a name.
Paco writes a short line,
concise and illustrative,
with the name
of the application.
This will be shown to the users,
for example during verification.
The name, unlike the identifier,
can be changed later
and is more flexible
when it comes to characters.
Following the registration
application,
the next field contains
the authorization options
for the users
of Paco's application.
The options are the following:
Open to all users
with a Google account;
Closed to a Google Apps domain;
Open to all users
with an OpenID provider.
As most users
already have a Google account,
Paco selects the first option,
Open to all Google accounts.
In the next lesson,
we will take a look
at the user service
where Paco will use
this configuration
to control access in detail.
Once the application
is finished,
Paco clicks on the button
"Create Application"
and will be sent
to the control board
of his new application,
which is empty
and without data.
From now on,
if Paco accesses
the appengine.google.com
address again,
he will see a list
with the identifier, name,
storage scheme and the state
of his new application
with the link to the remote
administration panel.
Upon finishing this process,
the census application
will have a designated address
and assigned resources
for it use.
Now Paco's ready
to publish his application
on the Internet
with Google App Engine.
Do you remember the identifier
and the authorization option
selected during registration?
Keep them in mind,
because you'll need them later.
That's all.
Keep programming!
KEEP PROGRAMMING!